is the input okay so X is the input f of
X is the output what we want to do with
an inverse function is we want to
reverse that so that now if X is taking
you to f of X okay the inputs taking you
to the output we want a function that's
going to reverse that and take you from
the output back to the input so
something that undoes the function I'll
just give you a simple example like you
know say for example you multiply
something by two okay so if we put three
in here okay so three is our input six
is our output what would be the opposite
of multiplying by two dividing by two so
what you can see here is if you put this
output in six divided by two takes you
back to three so multiplying and
dividing are inverses adding and
subtracting our inverses squaring square
rooting our inverses there's a lot of
different functions that are inverses of
one another but what we're trying to do
is we're trying to find an equation find
a function that undoes that original
process so when you take a look at
inverse functions okay in their graphs
what you'll notice is that the graphs
are reflections over the line y equals x
this 45 degree line so for example if
you were graphing y equals 2x that would
have a slope of 2 if you're graphing y
equals 1/2 X that would have a slope of
1/2 and you can see these graphs are
reflections over that line y equals x
but suffice it to say here what we're
trying to do is we're trying to reverse
that whole process of going from the
input to the output and so I'll show you
some more examples on how we're going to
do that so there's a couple different
ways to approach this one way is like an
intuitive way and what you can do is you
can say all right following the order of
operations I'm multiplying X by 5 and
then I'm subtracting 10 so we'll just
write x 5 minus 10
so multiplying by five and subtracting
ten if you wanted to reverse that you're
going this direction okay you're gonna
add ten first and then divide by five so
what our equation would look like is
you're going to take ax you're gonna add
10 first and you're going to divide by
five so this would be your inverse
function after to the -1 this represents
the inverse function so that's one way
to do is just in an intuitive way
instead of multiplying by five first
okay and then subtracting 10 you're
gonna reverse that you're gonna add 10
to ax which is the input and then divide
by five but what most teachers teach and
what most books show is just a simple
process that I'm going to show you now
and then all you're going to do is
you're just going to think of f of X as
Y you're going to switch the X and the y
and they're going to solve for the new Y
so to do that we're going to add 10 to
both sides we're gonna then divide by 5
and now you have y equals or we could
say f inverse of X instead of y equals x
plus 10 over 5 this is our inverse
function okay let's take a look at
another example another example f of x
equals x minus 2 divided by 4 so what
I'm going to do is think of this as Y
I'm going to switch the X and the y so x
equals y minus 2 divided by 4 and now
I'm going to solve for the new Y so I'm
going to multiply both sides by 4 okay
I'm going to add 2 to the other side
okay and now instead of writing Y I'm
going to write F inverse so this is F
inverse of x equals 4x plus 2 okay last
example y equals x squared plus 4 now I
showed in another past video how when
you look at these graphs okay y equals x
squared plus 4 looks like that it's a
parabola that's been shifted up 4 but
you see how it fails the horizontal line
test so that means that this equation
this function doesn't have an inverse
but what we can do is if we just look at
1/2 or just part of this graph let's
just say this right branch here where X
is greater than 0 X is greater than or
equal to 0
okay so we're working with this right
half now it does pass the horizontal
line test it only crosses at most once
so now we can go ahead and find the
inverse of this graph we're going to do
the same process we've been doing we're
going to switch the X and the y okay so
instead of y equals x squared plus 4
we're going to write this as x equals y
squared plus 4 okay and we're gonna
solve for the new Y so I'm going to
subtract 4 I'm going to take the square
root of both sides so we have y equals
plus or minus the square root of x minus
4 okay now remember how we talked about
how inverse graphs are reflections over
the line y equals x this 45-degree line
we've reflect this graph over this line
we're gonna get a parabola that looks
like this now you can see it fails the
vertical line test this is not a
function but if we're just working with
this positive branch right here okay the
part to the right of the x-axis the
reflection of that over line y equals x
is
this part here that's above the x-axis
so we're only going to want the positive
one here not this negative branch okay
so if we're finding the inverse of this
equation where X is greater than or
equal to zero we want y equals positive
square root of x minus four if we were
looking at the left branch here we would
want the negative portion so this has
been a introduction to finding inverses
of functions if you need to review the
video go ahead and do so and I'll see
you in the next video